[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello.
This course covers the key steps
to adopting Agile development
in your API program.
From our combined
experience at Google,
the first start to any
adoption is a mindset shift.
Agile software development
just makes sense.
And if you've been through
traditional waterfall
development, you know about the
big handovers, big team silos,
and difficulty in
collaborating, and plan change.
The values and principles
espoused in this manifesto
will derive and underpin a broad
range of software development
frameworks, but
primarily seek to solve
the root causes of the software
development in waterfall.
The term Agile was
popularized by the Manifesto
for Agile Software Development.
Take a moment to read through
it and visit their website.
Agile can be adopted in many
different software settings
within the digital value
chain for our course.
We focus on the Agile
method of developing APIs
by the API team.
A core part of Agile is to have
one cross-functional API team.
This means the
API team should be
largely self-sufficient with as
few dependencies as possible.
Here's what the Agile
API team would look like.
The core API team is in the
middle with one team made up
of the API product owner,
API developers, QA engineers,
and SCRUM master
in the inner ring.
They are constantly
working together.
The outer ring represents
also core team members
who may not be fully
dedicated to the API team,
and might be partially
allocated over time
to support multiple API teams.
The role of connecting
with non-core team members
are represented
with arrows showing
specific individuals who
should take ownership
of these key activities.
We explore each one of the
roles and relationships in depth
throughout this course.
For teams starting
out with Agile,
one of the biggest pitfalls
is taking on too much scope.
A great way to adapt
to changing plans
is to reduce the size of each
software scope implement.
Developing software
in a new way can
be difficult for
inexperienced teams.
So a smaller scope is
even more ideal for them.
Size the scope of
your API project right
and focus on the
minimum viable product.
Ask your team, what
is the least we
need to build that will
still deliver business value?
The picture here shows
three different ways
to build a transport
device over four releases
with a business goal
of getting from point A
to point B. The first
example should be avoided,
which is building incrementally.
After each release,
there's no business value.
Since we only get
from point A to B
until the very end
in release four.
The second example is better.
It achieves the goal of getting
from A to B in each release
with a working device.
But it forces the team to rework
the product in every release,
leading to a lot of waste
and throw away effort.
The third example
is the MVP approach.
We can transport from
A to B in each release.
But we have minimal
rework since we're
built on top of the previous
releases functionality
in a smart sequence.
You can think of Agile API
development in just this way.
Deliver the right MVP and pay
close attention to the sequence
you are releasing your new APIs.
To be really efficient, it's
not enough to release often
but to release with
quality and with the least
amount of effort.
Instead of writing test cases
after development is complete,
write the test cases and define
the success criteria upfront
in design before the
development starts.
This practice comes
in two flavors,
test-driven development, and
behavior driven development.
Both are very similar and
achieve the same outcome.
Both methods output
code that can then
be automated by QA engineers
who can string together
a series of unit tests and
tests written through TDD or BDD
to becoming integration
level tests for the API.
By running test cases that
are programmable scripts,
we can run the tests
over and over again,
taking a huge load off the
traditional QA bottleneck
and makes turnarounds on the QA
feedback loop incredibly fast.
For more information
about testing,
refer to the QA strategy
course later on in this series.
The principle of
automation is quality--
is an essential part of
Agile transformation.
No other practice
represents this
better than setting up
a continuous integration
and continuous
deployment pipeline.
This shortened acronym is CI/CD.
The main goal is to prevent
integration hell, where
multiple developers
begin integrating
large chunks of code near the
later phases of the project.
To avoid this drama,
the picture to the left
illustrates a recurring
cycle from code check
in, to testing, to
deployment, of the API bundle,
to updating the
API documentation.
The purpose to do this cycle
on a frequent basis or even
on a per code commit basis.
By using software like
Jenkins and programming
to move code from each
one of these steps,
this process can be
largely automated.
This reduces human effort
and increases the frequency
that the cycles run so that
errors are caught early
starting from the
first week of coding.
This practice of mastering
the CI/CD pipeline
is essential in adopting
Agile development.
Now that we have a good grasp
of the fundamental strategies
and tactics of adopting
Agile, let's discuss
the process of implementation.
Here's the familiar
waterfall process,
long release with lengthy
stages and big handover points
often from one team to
another with risk and unknowns
unsurfaced until we get
into that particular stage.
You've probably been through
it and have some pretty
interesting stories to tell.
Teams that move
away from waterfall
have a tendency to
move into SCRUM fall.
It breaks the work into sprints
and starts testing cycles
early on so it
helps the team pivot
and provide early
visibility into progress.
However, because testing is
separated as a post sprint
activity and not included
during requirements definition
and sprint, testing and bug
fix time is elongated and long
release cycles
invariably happen.
If you have large scope
that you can't break apart,
this is still better
than waterfall.
However, with API development,
and most software development,
we can definitely go
further than SCRUM fall.
The first important
tactic to avoid SCRUM fall
is to merge development
and QA into one sprint.
This likely means you will
take on less work in the sprint
to give time for bug fixing.
But with testing and fixing
merged into the sprint,
you've tested and ready
to release functionality
at the end of each sprint.
This gives us the
real ability to pivot.
Make this your first
goal for the team.
Just testing furiously during
development isn't enough.
We need to incorporate the
principle of definition
of quality up front.
If developers are not fully
aware of the test criteria
or QA engineers have to
spend more of their time
defining their test
criteria in the sprint,
precious time will be
wasted in the sprint.
Have the QA engineers
and the developers work
with the requirements
to define the test
criteria ahead of the sprint.
This can be done using
test-driven development
method or the behavior
driven development
we spoke about earlier.
Go as far as having the test
scripts coded so that the QA
engineers are just making
minor modifications
in the sprint itself.
With testing
definition brought up
in between requirements
and sprints,
your last step is to
automate the CI/CD pipeline.
Don't shortcut or
give up on laying down
the foundation for automation,
testing, and optimizing
the team's process.
With time, your team will
come to trust the process
as the testing begins to speed
up development and quality.
Now that we have a higher level
approach down, let's dive a bit
deeper into the Agile process.
There are two common
variant processes
in Agile, SCRUM and Kanban.
Please take a moment to
read the descriptions.
While SCRUM has more
processes with more steps
to take into account,
the cycle of development
is more familiar to many teams
and more friendly for new teams
being formed.
Kanban, although
easy to pick up,
relies on work that are
smaller chunks of effort
and less dependent
on other work.
Teams that have been working
well together who can really
self manage in Agile may be
better at picking up Kanban.
For the purpose
of this course, we
will focus on SCRUM given
its complexity and higher
rates of adoption.
Whichever process you
pick, commit to it.
Don't switch back and
forth until you really
feel like the team has lived and
learned through that process.
Since the SCRUM process
can be quite complex,
we're going to step through
this process one at a time.
A product owner is the
starting point at step one.
It all begins with a vision.
From this vision, we
develop an API roadmap.
This should be a high level
scope of the components needed
to achieve this vision
and deliver value
for the organization.
This roadmap can
include different sets
of APIs, business adoption, apps
usage, key compliance efforts,
infrastructure, and
even improvements
to the developer portal.
With a product
roadmap, focus on what
will be the first
valuable release.
Keep in mind the MVP principle.
Now that you have the scope
of your first release,
it should be quickly turned
into a rank list of requirements
in step two.
These requirements are written
in the form of epics and user
stories.
Often at this
point, the habit is
to go into a lot of
requirements detail.
Don't.
Instead of going deep, list
all the high level features
and requirements.
If you're spending more
than a week on this,
you're likely going to deep.
Step three is where most of
the recurring action process
happens.
The API team will select the
most important user stories
to work on for
the coming sprint.
The user stories have
to be fully fleshed out
with business, technical,
and testing details.
The API team will
review each user story,
break down the activities into
tasks needed to build this user
story, estimate the
effort, and commit
to a set of user stories
for the next sprint.
Each sprint can be one
to four weeks in length.
But we often see teams settle on
two weeks as the happy medium.
At the end of the
sprint, the user stories
should be completed
and ready for go live.
Anything not finished will be
carried over to the next sprint
or place back to
the product backlog.
This sprint cycle
repeats itself again.
Throughout the sprint cycle,
the SCRUM master is the coach
and tracks the
team's productivity
through burn down
and burn up charts
to measure the team's progress
in the form of velocity.
We will cover velocity
later in this course.
In addition to
tracking progress,
several ceremonies
are core to SCRUM.
These key ceremonies are listed
in steps four, five, and six.
In step four, the daily SCRUM
is a daily 30 minute activity
where each member talks
about the progress they made,
their task for the
day, and any blockers.
This is the time for the team to
take the pulse of the progress,
and drive action, and ask
for help in step five,
a sprint review, also
known as the sprint demo,
occurs at the end of the sprint.
It's generally meant to
recap what has been built
and provides a moment to
celebrate and to publicize
the achievements of the team.
In step six, the
sprint retrospective
is a ceremony also at
the end of the sprint.
The teams comes together to
self reflect on what went well
and what could be improved.
Oftentimes, the
best improvements
come from a team retro.
One area of confusion
we encounter
is what happens in between
the steps from product backlog
to finish work.
The ceremonies are
fairly easy to understand
but the sequence can be a
bit tricky to visualize.
Let's unpack this a bit more.
Taking another view
of a sprint by sprint,
you will see a repeating pattern
where the product backlog
items are refined prior to
the start of development.
This repeating effort is
called backlog refinement.
A team process that
is usually established
in the beginning
of the project is
called the definition of ready.
This checklist is the
agreement within the team
of when a story
is refined enough
for the developers and the QA
engineers to start the sprint.
Thus, this is a clear target
for even the team members doing
refinement on how far
they need to go to meet
the definition of ready.
Refinement is a
collaborative activity.
It's very important that the
product owner, API architect,
and QA engineer all focus on
the same set of user stories
in the priority
order of the backlog.
After they are done
with refining S1,
they move on to S2
and refine that set.
This continues until the
backlog is all refined.
Once a set of user stories
in sprint one is refined,
sprint planning starts as
either a recurring activity
before the sprint
in small chunks
or one larger session at the
first activity of the sprint.
The output of sprint
planning is a full set
of tasks per user story.
With this, the team goes to
work on development and test
scripts writing in execution.
This process continues
iteratively in sprint two,
three, and so forth.
The team also needs
to set the definition
of done for a user story at
the start of the project.
This is the line
for the team to draw
in terms of the standard
of finish and quality
that should be adhered to.
This way, there's no
misunderstanding at the end
of the sprint when a user
story is marked done.
It's up to the team as a whole
to enforce this standard.
In the last step,
finished work can
be queued for product
release and bundled
in the release per sprint.
The automated CI/CD pipeline
helps the last leg of process
quickly flow from
test and approve code
into the main branch.
We cover a ton of concepts
and strategies in this course.
To summarize, create
cross-functional teams
and close the ties
between IT and business.
Avoid legacy and
waterfall processes
so you can deliver
a smaller scope
and pivot on a regular basis.
Always look for ways to automate
and reduce any big handovers.
Use methods like behavior
driven development and concepts
like definition of
ready and definition
of done to build quality
into the process.
And align the teams on
a shared expectation.
Don't worry.
You won't get it
perfect on day one.
Use the feedback loops
like the sprint ceremonies
to take feedback and optimize.
Every Agile team will tailor
their process over time.
If there's one more last
principle of Agile to remember,
this is about
continuous improvement.
That's your North star.
I hope this course
has helped you
get a firmer grasp on
transforming into an Agile
development team.
If you want more
information, please check out
the community for
ebooks, articles,
and other related topics.